at the start of my audition before I
sang I mentioned that I had three
children and was a young mother and Katy
Perry made a joke
um
that
wasn't super kind
American Idol contestant Sarah Beth
lieba speaks out after some viewers
accused Katy Perry of mom shaming her on
the show it all went down earlier this
month when Sarah Beth auditioned for the
hit singing competition show I'm 25 and
I'm from California cannot be 25 what do
you
three kids
Lionel Richie Luke and Katy Perry were
shocked to learn Sarah's a proud mama of
three we'll try Katie no it's okay if
Katie Lays on the table I think I'm
gonna
pick three kids honey you've been laying
on the table too much
well that moment had some viewers
rushing to Sarabeth's defense online
Sarah Beth saw all the chatter and
posted this clip in response addressing
the awkward exchange and thanking
everyone for their support it was
embarrassing to have that on TV and it
was hurtful I think that women
supporting and uplifting other women is
so cool and I think that Mom shaming is
super lame and I think that it's hard
enough to be a mom and it's hard enough
to be a woman
ET has reached out to Katie's Reps for
comment but Sarah Beth concluded her
post with a message of encouragement for
all the mamas out there you're worthy
and
um
keep loving your babies nobody deserves
to
nobody deserves to feel crappy about
that I have a little family got married
young and now living that life now
I am definitely grateful to be able to
get to stay home with my kids pretty
much full time of course Katie is mom to
a three-year-old daughter Daisy whom she
shares with her longtime love Orlando
Bloom she's also a stepmom to Orlando's
12 year old son Flynn with ex Miranda
Kerr bill most fulfilling it feels full
it's it's beautiful I now know that
unconditional love as for Sarah Beth
yeah
she ultimately got the green light to
Hollywood from Luke and Katie you're a
yes
it's gonna have to be a no for me this
trip I'm sorry
I mean
yeah
and while some fans didn't like Katie's
comments to Sarah Beth earlier this week
the singer earned praise for how she
supported fire a young single mom she
didn't make it through the audition but
Katie encouraged her to come back and
try again in Nashville
you're going to show us what the fire is
okay I know you didn't name yourself
that for nothing
she's coming to Nashville fantastic we
support them we nurture them we give
them constructive criticism and so we we
just like teach them everything we know
in all of our years and even if they
don't win American Idol they go home
just like full of so much hope
foreign